hello ladies and gentlemen how do you do
uh thanks for coming to this uh uh Civic
media Communications for event um we
decided to try something uh really
stupid this time which was to complicate
uh perfectly good format uh by trying to
take a core sample from a variety of
people who are experts in a variety of
places uh to get a sense of how New
Media is affecting Civics and places
that are going through a lot of
difficult socio and political changes uh
and and to do it as a way to get a kind
of a sense of change part of the
motivation for this was uh that you know
there there are a lot of claims of
Twitter revolutions and SMS revolutions
and that these things are dramatically
changing people's ability to report or
affect social change within different
contexts and we thought that we would
ask people who are experts in a variety
of areas uh what their experiences with
these new media have been um we could
have brought one person to comment on
all of them and that person probably
would have been Ethan zerman
um but uh we decided that we would
instead pair Ethan with a variety of
people and allow him to ask informed
questions of them um they will be coming
in via Skype uh and if everything goes
really well um uh it'll be a smooth kind
of talk show host sort of experience um
the people's faces will show up on that
screen Ethan will be showing uh pictures
of them and and you know uh images uh
perhaps of their work a couple of them
um but we're mostly focused on audio so
feel free to lean back back in your seat
close your eyes and present pretend
you've got NPR on um I will ask that
people don't download a lot of Torrance
uh just because we don't want to
overload the network so um you know try
no major downloads uh uh don't don't put
on your Jammers or anything like that um
I've also been asked by the
communications Forum to announce uh the
event happening next week um same same
time same place uh Thursday April 2nd
and uh we're welcoming back uh uh
co-founder of the center for future Civ
media and former director co-director of
comparative media studies Professor
Henry Jenkins um uh helped create the
comparative media studies uh program
here some time ago uh he'll return from
his new job at USC uh where he eats
lotuses and sips nectar um uh to spend a
night talking about his years at MIT uh
and about the intellectual framework
that made CMS possible uh so actually
not the same place uh jenkins's farewell
takes place in Barto theater in the old
media lab building one week from today
um and the following day a dayong
celebration of cms's 10th anniversary
takes place in the new edition to the
media lab now most of you and they're
Flyers outside as well most of you uh
know uh the man to my left uh Ethan
zukerman um I've had the great pleasure
of knowing him for a few years uh he was
one of the co-founders of tripod.com uh
a really important early web hosting
service um he also founded geek core uh
uh which gets Awards both for creativity
of mission and name um which was
essentially taking Geeks and bringing
them around the world to work on
information activism and uh
infrastructure um Ethan is a fellow at
the uh birkman Center at Harvard uh he
uh is on The Advisory Board of the uh
Wikipedia foundation and um uh does many
many other things that too many to uh to
explain except I just found out that
he's going to give a talk at the
inaugural opening event of the George
Bush Think Tank um at Southern meth
Methodist is it Southern Methodist
University on Monday yeah in Dallas on
Monday so if you're in dallis uh please
please join Ethan for what will surely
be a uh spectacular talk I'm really
really really Hing that to wear shoes
okay there we go yeah um you never know
what will get thrown so um except you
never get thrown so uh so with with that
um we put Ethan in a very difficult spot
of interacting with uh uh complicated
technology across a bunch of different
places um but he's going to introduce
the format uh talk a little bit about
how you can ask questions uh both those
of you in The Ether and those of you
here um uh could you raise your hand if
you're by a computer that's a question
computer uh those are the three question
computers back there uh over here and
over here so if you've got a question um
come on over and enter it into the
software that we have here people online
will vote which questions get asked uh
and then the questions will get
refreshed between speakers um so Ethan
well thanks very much Chris and uh
welcome this is our uh attempt more or
less to replicate an NPR experience I
want you to think of me as your Chris
lien today uh I'm I'm going to be your
local radio host and I'm going to be
doing my best to broker a conversation
with Fascinating People from around the
world uh who you are capable of seeing I
am not capable of seeing uh but you know
I've always admired Chris and everybody
else who manages uh to do radio and make
it look smooth and seamless uh one of
the things that discovered is that to be
able to do this uh you need a massive
production staff and we've been very
very lucky to have people here working
with us uh and uh let's keep our fingers
crossed that this is all going to work
out um let me first say that we're
inviting everyone to participate and ask
some questions uh this is a great
burkeman Center MIT collaboration uh I
realize how shocking it is for MIT
people to be using Harvard software uh
but I wanted to welcome you to uh pull
up this URL and feel free to put up
questions I'll be showing it between
speakers so if you feel like asking a
question you can put up a question for
the question tool and then I will do my
best to broker these questions to our
speakers who are going to be calling in
from all around the world um just to
frame our
conversation um we're at a moment in
time where there's an enormous amount of
interest in participatory citizen or
Civic media depending on how we're
defining these different things and
really tremendous promises are being
made for the power of the this new
technology depending on who you ask the
power of Twitter and Facebook LED tens
of thousands of Iranians to take to the
streets put on green and March against
uh a fraudulent election the flip side
to which is or maybe that's not what
happened uh maybe in fact there was a
movement that figured out some very
clever ways to use citizen media to
promote itself to The Wider world but
citizen media wasn't necessarily the
organizing force behind it our question
is that one in part and in fact we're
going to start off with a couple of
experts on Iranian media but we're going
to broaden the conversation from there
and we're going to ask questions about
much broader applications of Citizen
media uh this is a photo of um a small
town in Madagascar which is in fact
where we're going to end up at the end
of this conversation talking about how
citizen media has made it possible for
youth groups who are organizing
themselves uh around cyber cafes around
a club CL that teaches English
journalism and online media to
participate in a climate debate taking
place in Denmark via Skype from an
outdoor link which is at least as
complicated and sophisticated as the
amazing amount of technology that we
poured out today so we're going to look
at this whole spectrum of Civic media
from Civic media as revolutionary media
and asking whether we think that's in
fact what's going on all the way through
to Civic media as a way of giving people
a chance to participate in digital
public spaces that they might not
otherwise have and to start this off
we've got with us Cameron ashro who's
the co-founder and the international
projects devel uh director of access now
um he teaches at the department of
geography and anthropology at California
State University at Pomona he's starting
his PhD studies focusing greatly on
these issues and Cameron we're going to
ask you to tell us first of all a little
bit about what is access now and what
was its role uh in the Green Revolution
in Iran
and do we have any audio from
Cameron hello great we've got you now
Cameron can you start again okay yeah
well first of all thank you so much for
inviting me to be here it's an honor to
be speaking and Ethan it's nice to see
you again it's so glad to be here and so
everybody can hear me
okay uh let me change the input here
volume you're doing great we'll we'll
we'll worry about it on our side you're
just keep talking we got you okay okay
so the question was what is access now
and what has been our well how have we
helped with the
Iranian uh movement online yeah
basically what what's the function of
access now and then sort of beyond that
access now I know it's very heavily
involved with video I would love for you
to talk about citizen video and the
Green
Revolution sure well a little bit
uh a little bit about
access excuse me you're fine go ahead
okay a little bit about access now uh
basically access now is a global
movement for digital Freedom that also
provides uh digital relief team and I'll
I'll talk more about that and then a
little bit about our Global movement for
Freedom we we do a variety of things and
one of them is of course as you
mentioned the video project which is
helping to secure citizen media that you
know in since we're talking about the
context of Iran that came out of Iran uh
securing citizen media providing a being
a link between citizen journalists and
citizen media and the mainstream media
and basically being able to Archive
these videos and provide downloads we've
had millions of down videos downloaded
from Iran uh of the protest in formats
that are compatible with mobile phones
and other sorts of technology that
people use there that's a basically the
focus of our video thing our video
aspect and I'll be talking about that
later as you said uh we we protect
dissident blogs uh from attack and
things of that sort uh so that they're
not taken down by the regime uh and and
deface in other ways like that we also
are building a Global movement hopefully
for digital Freedom where we would have
a a massive involved citizenry around
the world uh basically advocating for
digital rights and helping to build a
global proxy cloud of some sort which
we're we still in development right now
that could hover over
could hover over areas that are being
threatened by unusually harsh internet
filtering or Internet uh restrictions
and everything and similar like that and
also to also be a policy arm as well so
that we can advise on issues of Internet
freedom and and digital activism around
the world so we have we're very diverse
organization as you can see we have a
lot of different sides to us and and are
we're born out of the Iran election
which is where our main experience is
right now so so let me just sort of jump
in for a moment and and sort of Hit the
highlights on that one um basically
access now is born out of the experience
of trying to figure out how to support
uh activists during the Iranian election
protests that's had to do with
maintaining websites for people in the
green movement because there's been a
very active movement to take down some
of these sites via distributed denal
service this is now turning into uh an
attempt to create a giant proxy Cloud
basically a way for Iranians to access
the internet through third parties um
but sort of at the core of all of this
is a video archive and access now has
been collecting citizen video uh from
all around the internet putting it
together what what was the importance of
video in Iran and then maybe even more
than that how did all this video come
out of Iran why didn't the Iranian
government cut off links and make it
more difficult for people to transmit
video from within
Iran well the importance of uh that's a
great question the importance of video
uh
some of these videos have gotten
hundreds of thousands of views um the
importance of video has also has been
one of the okay the way I like to
explain it is that information is very
segregated in Iran for instance you know
in in the context of the green movement
and the the post-election protest people
in certain cities didn't know what was
happening in other cities people in
shiras didn't know what was happening in
tan and things like that and so one of
the things you had was these videos
enabled people to know that there was a
broader support network out there of
green activists that there were events
happening in other cities that it wasn't
just them against the world them out
there alone um the one of the other Mo
very important aspects of this was that
it helped to counter propaganda it
helped to show when for instance when
there were there were reports coming out
that there was no protest there was
nobody on the streets and you had videos
from the same day of hundreds of
thousands of people marching in the
streets so it also helped to Galvanize
supporters it helped for them to
identify strategies and techniques that
they could use in their protests and so
video played a very important role and
and also to inform the outside world of
what was happening in Iran and I can
feel you know I I am half Iranian and I
can feel that there's been a shift in
the perception of Iranians because of
these videos have gotten out that we're
not you know all plotting to build our
own homegrown nuclear weapons in our in
our garages um and that it's really
helped to show the Irani people you a
different side of them I I think there's
absolutely no question that the videos
and uh particularly the Naga sulan video
were enormously important for sort of
raising the profile of the grieved
movement in the US what's really
surprising for me to hear is the
importance within Iran which is to say
that you had videos and they were a way
for people within Iran to see that other
people were involved with the movement
in other cities that this wasn't just
constrained to tan um I again I find
myself fascinated we've seen other
governments China for instance cut off
the entire province of
umumi uh when people started using the
internet as a way of spreading
information about the protest why do you
think uh Iran allowed the internet to
stay up that's an excellent question I
was actually having that believe it or
not I I was actually having that same
discussion this morning with a student
activist who's relatively prominent and
he was telling me you know that
basically Iran has such a high level of
Internet penetration I think it's over
30% and also with that high level
internet penetration is a high level
internet penetration among the
government and among commercial entities
so any wholesale shutdown of the
internet would would disrupt such a
enormous sizable chunk of the population
that it couldn't be sustained for very
long is this at least as this is as is
my opinion and what I've what I've seen
and when I've spoken with activists
throughout Iran and outside of Iran that
that is just become too much a part of
commercial culture government culture
and Civic culture and citizen culture to
be shut down for any long period of time
without there being some sort of uh
adverse effect of this happening of
people being more outraged of it adding
fuel to a fire already tense situation
and that seems actually very consistent
with what actually happened as far as
how the Iranian internet was controlled
based on um people mostly folks like
Arbor network based in Boston who were
monitoring uh connections to Iran what
people saw was a degrading of
connections rather than uh actually
having them shut down and so the idea
was essentially to try to keep up email
but not necessarily to make it possible
for people to look at things like
streaming video and we saw a lot of
blockage of that I know that there was a
movement before the elections to try to
get video cameras into the hands of
ordinary Iranians that Los angeles-based
uh television St were saying that they
were sending in pen cameras is there any
truth to any of that or was this just
people with their own cameras and mobile
phones and the natural level of
Technology penetration within Iran that
made this
possible um I think it was true that
there were I did see some videos that
purported to be shot by the pen cameras
that you say so I do think that there
was at least some truth to it how much
truth I don't know and how many of those
videos uh all the the enormous amount of
videos that that we've seen and that
I've personally seen how many of those
were shot with a pen VI cameras I don't
know but I do know some were so I do
believe that there was some truth to
that uh but it seems to me from what I
know that these are just regular people
with with their cell phones with their
digital cameras shooting these reg these
videos and just transporting them uh
electronically to the outside world
themselves so I don't think there's no
outside organization or group uh that's
funneling video cameras to Iranians for
the express purpose of Citizen media
propagation so we've uh we had the
amazing experience uh in the US of
essentially watching this revolution
unfolding in real time uh there were a
lot of people who uh desperately wanted
to support uh the movement um we had
people working really really hard uh to
try to uh essentially reinforce and
retweet and sort of spread this
information back and forth as much as
possible and then of course um the
impression that we've gotten here was
that the movement has really been forced
to go
underground uh it's not clear how much
energy there is behind it um are we not
getting a picture of what's going on
right now in the green movement or is it
accurate to say uh that a lot of the
protest has been successfully squelched
at this point uh uh by the Iranian
authorities well I think that's a very
complicated question
honestly I think that maybe for the time
being at least the enormous protest that
we saw in June and at other events that
have happened since uh maybe it's
temporarily not happening but I think
one of the things you you have that
that's really happening is a culture
like a culture of resistance this is
that maybe there's not massive amounts
of people outside but people feel things
in their heart people feel the the
student culture the young culture you
know middle-age culture has has changed
in in some way so I think what you're
seeing is not so much people are being
out in the street but I see I think
you're seeing people whose opinions have
changed people whose thoughts have
changed and that's a that's much more
difficult to squelch than protesters so
I think you've seen a real fundamental
shift in attitudes and beliefs and
opinions of the government and that's a
very very difficult thing to stop camon
second do you see that turning into a
future movement are are we going to see
Green Revolution part two or do you
think this is much more of a subtle
change where as you sort of suggesting
seeing the movement seeing the
possibility of resisting watching
through citizen media the movement
spreading to different parts of the
country do you think that's going to
lead to another acute sort of Revolution
type change or do you think it's a much
longer deeper change within the Iranian
psyche I really think it's a much uh
longer and deeper change honestly I
don't think we're going to see a
spontaneous uh you know huge outpouring
in the like I don't think we're seeing
like a a gisan type
event happened I think this is a
long-term change this is like Amir
Hussein mavi said that this is year of
patience this is this is a long gradual
gradual move and gradual shift so I
don't think it's I I don't think there's
a a from the people I talk with at least
doesn't seem to be a rush and urgency
that they know this this is going to be
a long a long movement and they're
prepared for that and comfortable with
that and so I think you're going to be
you're going to see this snowball as the
word gets out to The Villages as the
word gets out to other parts of the
country uh and that you're going to see
this slowly start to snowball into
something eventually over given enough
time so so if I'm if I'm sort of hearing
you correctly on on all of this um
access now which is really built almost
as sort of emergency media right you
know how do you get people around
censorship in real time um how do you
preserve this critical video that's
coming out at the moment it sounds like
you guys are needing to shift in focus
from sort of an acute struggle to to a
long-term one how does that change what
you guys are
doing this is access now we want to
support democracy movements and and we
recognize all of us that democracy
movements don't happen on like American
time you know they happen at their own
time and they don't happen on the
media's time and so we're prepared to
stand with democracy movements in their
struggle however long it takes whatever
they need and and this is one thing that
we see with the green movement we're
there in the time of you know heightened
activity intense protest but also the
the so-called laws right now like that
are you know seem to be happening right
now to outside observers so this is just
part of what access now does is support
democracy movements we're not there to
be there when it's cool and trendy we're
there for when it's not cool and trendy
too so so that that's a great reminder
and a place where I'd love to sort of
close off with you at this point Cameron
is that reminder that it's really easy
to pay attention to the stuff when it's
really hot everyone is paying attention
to a ular situation but maintaining
these efforts and trying to keep an eye
on what's going on within the green
movement and with other citizen
movements in Iran over time is sort of
the long-term challenge um we're going
to move over uh to talk to questions for
a few minutes sure uh do we want to take
questions from the audience before we
let you go Cameron sorry about that uh
do we have a question from the audience
that you want to bring in Chris uh we
don't have anything online yet uh maybe
this is a good chance to remind people
that uh they can enter cyber. law.
harvard.edu
questions difficult Civics actually uh
is it should be difficult uh than
Capital C Civics um and uh I just
figured that this whole event was so
difficult we were just that's exactly it
and in fact I've now put that slide in
eight times in the Des so you can just
remember that it's those of you online
just add Capital C Civics uh to the URL
but does anyone within the house want to
ask a question yeah I just go over here
yep that's fine sure why not mic go the
microphone that's fine yeah yeah I'm
curious about the details uh of how the
government goes about shutting down uh
internet media uh why are they not able
to do it easily I I have no idea
technically uh and how much can you
combat uh this is obviously going to be
happening in a lot of countries over
many years so I'd like to hear what the
struggle is
like um so so your question is basically
why haven't they again why haven't they
shut shut it down and I'm not exactly
sure exactly what your the question is
basically why is it difficult for the
government to shut down internet access
why is it technically difficult and why
is it socially difficult okay well as I
said earlier you know the internet has
really become an embedded part of a lot
of Iranian culture and you know with a
very very high a very very high level of
penetration especially among the youth
and like again in commercial entities
and government and everything so
shutting it down is extremely it's an
undesirable thing I don't think I don't
hold it past them and I think if
situation were to get severely unstable
I think that we'd probably see it but I
don't it's just too socially difficult I
think to shut down the internet for any
prolonged period of time and I think
that's a real main issue in in this
honestly there's actually very few
documented incidents of even very closed
societies shutting down the internet for
longer than 24 hours um basically it's
crippling to your local commercial
economy and so China's been able to do
it for iri mostly because this is
already a massively disconnected part of
China uh but as Cameron's been saying um
within Iran it would be difficult uh to
essentially maintain all the business
that goes on with the country uh while
being off the internet uh one question
that just came in and and I I think
we're going to let this be the last
question Cameron and then we're going to
go on to our next speaker um can you say
something about uh YouTube spefic
specifically uh what was the role of
YouTube in the green movement well
YouTube has been nothing short of of
just a fantastic partner for Access now
and in and for the green movement
especially uh YouTube has played such a
critical role they relaxed their
restrictions on violent content I'm sure
some of you might remember that during
the protest because what was happening
was people were going through whether
they were regime agents or not or you
know other people sympathetic people or
what have you and down voting and
basically getting these important videos
taken off that's one of the reasons we
archive these videos at access now is
that if they get taken off there's a
copy available for human rights NE
reasons or for legal tribunals and stuff
like that YouTube has also been very
proactive in addressing account
shutdowns of crucial accounts that get
suspended or whatever compromised you
that are within the green movement that
are within this video distribution
Network and they've been very proactive
in doing that and so they're helping to
keep those channels open to for
activists to be able to get their word
out and also one of the main problems is
with the international media that with
the it's not as a cool trendy topic like
we talked about with YouTube but on
YouTube it's still a big topic YouTube
is still done on their citizen Tu blog
and on their front page even in L
periods features on the Iranian protest
features on other democracy movements
around the world so YouTube I really
think is playing an extremely vital role
and and as they develop their
Technologies more I I I can really see
uh YouTube being a very very crucial uh
key player in in digital activism and
freedom movements around the world
they've been incredible behind the
scenes in helping and supporting uh
human rights activists it's been
incredible well that that's a that's a
great YouTube shout out we'll let them
uh know how how much you appreciate them
Cameron thanks so much for taking the
time to be with us it's really been a
pleasure to have you
here you so much and it was a pleasure
to be here an honor thank you so we're
we're gonna remain focused on Iran uh
and we're incredibly lucky to to have um
such knowledgeable speakers uh about
what's going on in irana and because I
know that there's such enormous interest
in what's G on uh with the green
movement uh and here we're now uh able
to welcome back to MIT uh our friend uh
Medi uh yayad uh and I apologize to the
extent that I've just gotten that wrong
uh but medy is um not only uh a physics
PhD from MIT uh but is really one of the
very critical figures uh in citizen
media in Iran uh before the election and
through the election uh with a site
called balatarin and balatarin uh can be
thought of in some ways as the Dig or
the Reddit uh of Iran but in many ways
it's actually much more special than
that uh so medy I I wanted to invite you
first of all to uh to tell us a little
bit about the site that you've been
involved with and I've got the slides
here that I can show the audience uh but
what what is balatarin and and how has
it been important for for cific media in
Iran um hi everyone ban is very similar
to dig and Reddit in the way it works
it's a social news aggregator um B is a
place where Iranian finds what's
important today basically uh most people
especially journalists bloggers go to
bin to find out what is going on and
that's that's the question bin answers
pretty much every day for people uh who
visit bin um I think it in a way it's
Injustice B to compare to dig and redit
in uh because um the situation the
context is very different blogging in
Iran was much bigger than uh blogging in
the in the US in terms
of as a in the in comparison to the rest
of the media I mean uh us has a strong
history of newspapers other TV other
Medias but in in in case of Iran
Independent Media didn't have much uh
other alternative other than blogs and
because of the importance of the blogs
uh Bin also became important because B
has a multiplier effect for the voice of
bloggers a blogger uh who posts the
interesting content on his on his blog
or her blog uh might get 100 visitors a
day normally but because of
poin he gets uh tens of thousands
visitors and also since there are lots
of journalists who are active on
ballarin and they work for other places
such as BBC Persian TV or Voice of
America TV they they take that content
and they broadcast it through TV and
this that content which was produced by
a blogger might get uh shown to many
more people who who don't necessarily
have access to Internet so we're we're
looking at your slides right now and
we're looking at the daily reach of uh
balatarin in comparison uh to 's
official news agency uh and noticing
that there are a lot of days uh where
balatarin is
significantly uh better visited uh than
than
irna um that that that has to make this
uh incredibly powerful um have you guys
experienced uh censorship blockage uh
harassment and anything uh trying to
prevent people from accessing the
site so ban has been pretty much exposed
to um everything that the Iranian
government has it in power basically
from almost four months after B start
working which was four years ago uh the
website got uh blocked in Iran and still
people continue with accessing the
website through proxies we've had the
cases of hacking to the website we have
had uh cases of um Iranian probably
revolutionary guard writing a scripts to
be to find people's passwords so we've
had all sorts of things we've had in in
Iran in fact for a period of time maybe
it's still happening if you go to
bain.com you you go get not only see a
blocking page but also you get
redirected to another page set up by
Iranian government so it's a they've
tried many different things to um to
take people people off the website and
also we've seen misinformation too I
mean but is a user generated content so
it's a obviously there's a challenge a
challenge of uh people who are
government agents and use the platform
for misinformation and the I mean there
there there was one case last summer uh
there was a 12-year-old boy who was uh
killed in Iran and everybody thought
that he was killed in a demonstration
and that news got publicized in bin but
later it turned out that in fact he was
he was hit by truck so and Iranian
government used that what happened in
onar and several other website to show
um how these websites are I mean and
which categorizes them as opposition
websites are uh Distributing false news
and they are not credible so um we're
looking at a a slide here telling us
that that this is a site that's looked
at by uh 700,000 people every month if
you're looking at Bine from within Iran
you are circumventing censorship you're
using a proxy you're going around the
firewall do you have a sense for how
many of your users are Iranians who are
out in the diaspora and how many are
Iranians who are accessing the site from
within the
country we um for many reasons we don't
uh basically we don't talk about the
number of users in Iran because of
security reasons but uh for the visitors
based on Alexa report it seems there are
40% from Iran but we are um one of our
plans is to measure that directly it's
not an easy thing because uh people who
come to the website come through proxies
and there is a it's hard to find out
which which IP uh is a proxy IP and
which one is not but it's fair to say
that it's a mix of both Iranians in
country and expatriates absolutely so
the readers it's very mixed
unfortunately the contributors um if
Iranian censorship had an impact so that
that definitely had an impact and
because of many of the proxy software um
don't have an option of um Ajax calls so
because of part of the system works
through voting or many of the I mean in
terms of technical things there are lots
of use of Ajax because of that some of
the people in Iran are not able to
contribute so so let's let's talk about
um you guys started this Pro project in
part because the Iranian blogosphere
from very early on has been one of the
most dynamic one of the most powerful
one of the most political one of the
most diverse um so sort of two questions
there um there's a a perception that the
Iranian blogosphere really took off when
there was a Crackdown on Independent
Media in Iran and that people went from
writing newspapers to writing blogs at
the same time I know that there's a lot
of bloggers particularly those writing
in Persian uh who are quite conservative
uh who are supporting the regime um give
us a sense of the diversity of the sort
of conversations that take place in the
blog isphere and that take place on on
balarin so so I think once blogging
became fashionable I mean
anybody between age of 18 and 28 went on
blogging because it was just fashionable
I mean it wasn't something that it it
didn't depend on what political opinion
you have and in fact if you start
reading Iranian blogs you'll see that
most of the blogging is not about
politics it's not about even social
issues it's it's more about personal
freedom issues it's more about u in fact
there is a large uh section of Persian
bloggings about poetry poetry is a big
part of Iranian life and uh because of
that there are lots of blogs dedicated
to poetry and uh even they might touch
social and political issues but they
they still use a poetic language so many
of the things that in fact American
Media might be concerned like nuclear
issues or um some of more regional
political issues like war in Iraq or
Afghanistan in fact they are not
discussed that much in Persian blog
sphere and the things that are discussed
are mostly things that are affecting
their daily life in the post election U
Iranian postelection um events obviously
the bloggers became very political many
of them um of course were supporting
uh Mr MAV and some of them were
supporting Ahmed so there was a heated
discussion in uh in blogg sphere but I
would say in most cases uh political
blogging is just a portion of uh Persian
blogging and I I I would say it's not uh
it's probably less than 30% of it so I I
I was fascinated by this in some ways
because uh a colleague of mine John
Kelly uh did a map of the Persian
blogosphere and ended up clustering it
and and clustered sort of leftwing blogs
clustered right-wing blogs and then came
up with this huge poetry cluster uh
which was sort of fascinating and then
of course from Global voices we
translate uh a great deal uh from the
Persian blogosphere and and we've seen
much more
diversity uh than has really come
through in American Media uh and one of
the the posts that I know that we ended
up doing from Global voices uh was a
whole set of
proad uh blogs which made us very
unpopular because I think there was a
sense that the bloggers as a whole were
going to rise up uh and and join all
together in the Green Revolution it
actually turned out to be a bit more
complicated than that to what extent
does does Bine end up being a space for
the left or a space for the right or is
it a space that really everyone uses is
it sort of a public utility in that
sense so so at the beginning when B
started it was mostly uh it was very
diverse um in fact most of the postings
were about techn technology it was about
entertainment and uh But as time went on
because of Iranian government's uh
opposition in fact because they they
blocked the website they they they
accused the I mean in fact it was such a
weird thing for them I mean they
couldn't understand that where these
people who are users on the website are
coming from I mean there have been
accusations that I'm paying 30,000 users
on on the website which is ridiculous I
mean so basically the idea of social
media the content generated wasn't
something that could was understood by
Iranian officials who were over 30 year
old I mean so that was that was
something they couldn't understand and
because of that it just just it was such
a complicated thing for them and so
because of Iranian government's
hostility we started losing people who
were more sympathetic to the Iranian
government and also people who were more
poor democracy or um more liberal I
would say they they started becoming
more U upset by the the actions Iranian
government were taking in fact I mean
there is an strong identity voltarian
users feel very strong on the um
associate with the website with the the
brand and because of that when they see
for example the website got hacked by
the Iran government they became really
upset and that that obviously made them
more u in a in a way more agitated when
they saw people coming on the website
and posting content that that's more
sympathetic to the government so I would
say especially through the past year uh
the dominant language and the dominant
content on is the content posted by by
Iranian opposition more liberal more
Progressive that's not something we
intended to have that's that happened
mostly because of Iranian government
actions so um Bine I think is an
incredible example of what sort of
pressure Civic media uh can face and to
the extent that ballarin became a
politicized space it's faced all sorts
of attacks denial of service we have a
question here about social engineering
attacks I can tell you for a fact that I
know it's experienced social engineering
attacks censorship so on and so forth we
have one question here that I want to
put to you before we move on which is a
question about um working on such an
intensely important project from outside
Iran uh does the fact that you're
working on balarin uh from the United
States rather than from Iran are there
questions that come up about credibility
about whether you are up on uh the sort
of conversations that are actually
taking place in Iranian cyberspace is is
that an important aspect or do people
just sort of assume this is cyers space
no one really cares where you
are I think um so Iranian I mean
Community outside Iran has a is basic
divided to to community the one there's
one community that came here after R
Revolution and they've been here for 30
years old they very far from what's
happening in Iran I was more of a part
of the second generation that came here
more recently so the language I mean I'm
I I pretty much understand the context
and I in in most cases I don't highlight
that in fact we are based in the US
that's not something highlighted and the
the fact that the team is a virtual team
we have people in Europe we have people
in other part of the world that's for
helping me it it kind of um reduces that
tension and uh it it doesn't allow that
become an issue the I think one other
thing because we don't usually post that
many things on the website ourselves
it's the users who are doing it and we
are just providing a platform uh it's
becoming a less of an issue I mean it's
been a less of an issue obviously
Iranian government it takes advantage of
this I mean there is an Iranian
conservative newspaper called Khan that
repeatedly accuses U not only I mean the
fact that the website is supported by
CIA or mad it's it claims that the
website is owned by a um Israeli radio
uh editor of Israeli radio in Jerusalem
someone I never met I don't I don't know
of so it's basically they they got they
they don't care about the reality they
don't care where you are they they they
make up what they want
so in other words what whatever
perception there might be you would
probably be facing it if you were in
isan as well I I know from running a
similar citizen media um uh property uh
we look for people uh saying that we're
from the CIA and saying that we're from
George Soros and we sort of try to keep
score between the two uh we're currently
accused in Iran of being sponsored by
both the CIA and George Soros so I I
feel your pain uh but medy it's it's
been really a pleasure and uh balarin is
just a real
inspiration uh it's something that we
take a lot of inspiration from at Global
voices so I really want to thank you for
uh for joining us and being with us
tonight thank you for having me in MIT
thanks thanks so
much so just a a quick reminder for
everybody the URLs that I'm putting up
are broken uh but at the end of them if
you add Civics uh difficult represents
me Chris my relationship with Chris MIT
so on and so forth but this is in fact
the difficult Civics Forum rather than
just the difficult forum and fortunately
to make things slightly less difficult
uh we are now going to hand over to uh
my lovely talented uh colleague Georgia
poell who is uh the managing director of
global voices uh is one of the
Caribbean's leading bloggers uh the
Caribbean's first podcaster I believe uh
and uh really master of all citizen
media uh but rather than ask about her
sort of vast knowledge uh of of Citizen
media as a whole uh which Georgia has
because she's responsible day for day uh
for producing the global Voice's site
and all the content within Georgia I
wanted to ask you some very specific
questions uh which were basically what
the heck were you doing in
Haiti well we we went to Haiti to
basically see whether the the citizen
media surge we we saw after the
earthquake um was something that we
could build
upon um we managed to get a small ground
to do that and um I I live in Trinidad
900 miles to the the southeast of Haiti
so um was was a hop skip and a jump for
me
um and
um what happens is that after you know
years of attempting to to cover this
this country um that's really one of the
most difficult countries in the Western
Hemisphere to cover from a citizen media
standpoint we we saw on the evening of
the earthquake this unprecedented surge
of of activity notably on
Twitter and um you know where did all
these people come from so um the trip to
Haiti was really about about looking
more closely at that and also seeing
whether there was a role for citizen
media in the the relief efforts and
certainly in the
Reconstruction um efforts as well so so
let's let's just pause for a moment and
talk about sort of a citizen media
history of the Haitian earthquake
obviously earthquakes uh aren't like
revolutions uh no one's planning for
them ahead of time there's no ramp up to
them uh something tragic happens and
then everyone ends up reacting to it
what was the citizen media reaction uh
to the Haitian
earthquake the citizen media reaction
was was a very immediate um response on
on Twitter um some very kind of vivid uh
high quality tweets
describing basically what was happening
to people in PTO prance what people were
seeing from from their you know their
balconies and things like that and um
because Haiti is not a country that that
that's necessarily on on our radar all
the time there was and and where
correspondents don't have don't tend to
be there permanently this really was an
unprecedented view into into Haiti at
this particular time just into the
country in
general and um there were two or three
people who were really just giving just
really really kind of excellent
information there was also
a a guy in Canada who did a UST stream
hookup and was getting Haitians on the
phone the interesting thing is is that
the internet stayed up throughout I mean
Haiti doesn't have very good
uh
Georgia
so so um but the internet St yeah we
just lost the last minute or so of could
you start your answer Over Georgia you
you said that Haiti Haiti doesn't have
very good internet infrastructure and
then Trinidad's internet infrastructure
kicked in yeah you know look at
that my neighbors are all online now um
yes no TTI does not have a a very good
infrastructure in general in in in in no
no sense of the word but um but the
internet stayed up and the internet
became the the lifeline uh there was
also a journalist who who
um was actually he's actually not a
journalist he's a DJ and Signal FM was
the only radio station broadcasting and
he was using Twitter widely to even to
the point of asking people to to kind of
PayPal him money to be able to keep his
Skype account open and things like that
and um he was also doing a lot of the
the relaying of information people were
were calling in on their cell phones to
the station and he was relaying
information via Twitter to to various
places you know outside of the country
and within
so um what we ended up seeing sort of
from the outside of this at Global
voices was of course Something Like An
Earthquake happens everyone's attention
shifts over to that country and so Haiti
which we cover and have covered for
three years now um suddenly everyone
wants to know what's going on there's
this wave during which the tweets the
blog posts the photos are literally the
only information coming out of this
country and then very quickly we end up
with something different which is that
every major broadcast network around the
world deployed someone to Port a prince
what what happened to the citizen media
Community once the professional
journalists took
over sorry five seconds of your question
what happened to the citizen media
Community well so basically when the
mainstream media went in so it's sort of
two questions and I'll give you two in
the hopes that one of them will get
through um what happened to Civic media
uh when all the journalists hit the
ground and then what happens after those
journalists get back in the
airplanes okay that that's a very good
question the um the the mainstream media
dominated the um the the the the kind of
spectrum as soon as they arrived you
know not it'll be CNN with with its you
know dramatic kind of um rescues and
setups and medical interventions and
things like
uh the
um there was
however a kind of side Channel people
like this DJ carel ped continued to to
kind of um certainly the tweets they
were actually being pulled into the uh
to the the mainstream media narrative a
bit but it's true that that that for the
most part for the first say two weeks of
the earthquake the mainstream media
voice did drown out the citizen media
voice if if that is where you were
looking and I think for most people say
in the US it wasn't Twitter they were
looking at it was CNN and you know the
the New York Times lead was run was
running things on their Blog the Miami
Herald which has you know to their
credit has continued to cover Haiti
fairly thoroughly because you know
they're in a a city which has a strong
Haitian Community they have a number of
Haitian journalists on staff but it's
true that um that yes it did get tamped
down when the mainstream media so so I
think what what I'm really fascinated by
you packed up this huge duffel bag not
just of equipment but all the medical
supplies all the food anything you would
possibly need we are not CNN when we
deploy a reporter to Haiti this is
actually kind of a big deal for us and
when I say we deploy I don't actually
mean we I mean you uh since you actually
put all this together why is it so
important that Haitian citizen media be
able to continue this in the long run
what's Global Voice's interest in
building up hatian citizen
media well it a is a peculiar country in
that it's it's got very weak
institutions I think that that's widely
known so the Haitian media in general is
not a very kind of powerful
force uh so what is happening given that
Hai is also such a political football
and given that there 101 billion dollars
at stake what's happening is is is the
the kind of
classic thing that happens at a certain
point in humanitarian disaster and the
story becomes about what's happening
with the
aid you know who's giving what and they
all these these uh projects trying to
bring transparency to the process but
the what's actually going on in the
ground in Haiti is not getting out of
the country what also happened in Haiti
is that the um media Outlets took a
battering while we were there we tried
to make with with some newspapers and
radio stations but most of them weren't
operating so um I I think re rebuilding
just Haitian mainstream media is also an
issue it might even be be kind of more
important issue than than citizen media
there there has you know continued to be
a trickle of Citizen media activity
coming out of Haiti um notably from the
people who were blogging before which is
uh some Aid
workers some members of the diaspora
who've gone
back there's a a trickle on Twitter as
well every day because you know the
story is in the news because of all the
money at stake but um you know the the
Haitian Haitian media is is not you know
it's not robust at this point and I
think rebuilding it there number of
projects actually designed to to kind of
help rebuild it but I think that's a
really important issue so I I think uh
for a lot of us the first of all the
main surprise about citizen media in
Haiti uh was that there was citizen
media in Haiti I think a lot of us were
sort of uh tremendously surprised that
there was going to be media coming out
of it I think the next surprise uh was
that the internet managed to stay up and
allow citizen media to persist in the
face of this crisis um you know my my
question is really whether Haiti is
going to end up with enough media
whether it's citizen media whether it's
professional media to have the sort of
oversight it over this Aid and
rebuilding process we just had this
International Conference that committed
something like four times as much Aid uh
as the country had actually asked for
but we're pouring into a rather leaky
bucket this is one of the most corrupt
countries in the world how would we get
to the point where Haiti has a media
infrastructure capable of monitoring uh
what's going on with this Aid
money well
I I think that there's some
infrastructural work to be done just you
know the
you know just buildings for people to
work in need need to need to be be um
kind of created uh there's a training
aspect uh it's the Haitian media core is
probably not not the the best trained in
use of New Media tools um there's also
translation component and I know we at
Global voices we like to to push out
translation capacity but uh Haitian
media tends to be if it's radio it's
Creole a bit of French if it's uh print
it's French and um Creole isn't widely
written so the there things that that
are being written for the Haitian
audience within Haiti are very often not
getting out because of the language
barrier so so what are the what are the
sort of infrastructures mediation to be
done there that has to
translation but um but yeah not just the
the basic things that you know that one
does in order to to kind kind of keep a
a press alive you know need to be done
and um it's it's absolutely critical you
know I try to be optimistic about about
Haiti but having been there and seen the
extent of the of the damage and and
knowing what the context is it's it's
difficult to be but you know we have to
that's that's my neighbor in CARICOM as
well you know this affects me very
directly let let's take a a question
from the audience here Georgia thanks a
lot so a question for now and long term
for Georgia but maybe also for for you
guys so do you see in general the
relationship between the citizen media
and should we call it the traditional
media media as been mutually exclusive
symbiotic antagonistic somewhere
everywhere on the Spectrum and and some
examples sorry and are you talking about
Haiti in in particular yeah in your case
Haiti um right now I think citizen media
in Haiti is is so you know minimal and I
think a lot of Citizen media in Haiti
gets consumed outside of the country so
I I don't know that there's much of a
Consciousness you know among the the
kind of you know the media core in Haiti
that there's there's a kind of threat
from citizen journalism which is why I
think it's such a great opportunity um
we did see a couple of media Outlets
start to do things like you know put
videos on YouTube we saw the the senior
Institute in in Jack M the film school
start reporting and and and um putting
videos on a Blog so I I think this is
this is a great opportunity that that
considering that there's no real you
know the the the traditional antagonism
between mainstream media and citizen
media doesn't really exist there I think
it's there's a real opportunity for some
real
symbiosis and and and for journalists to
also kind of get involved in in being
citizen journalists you know doing
things you know publishing things that
they may not publish in their newspapers
online I I think just answering it from
the global voices perspective where we
both work um that antagonism has really
fallen off over the years um that two or
three years ago it wasn't
uncommon uh to see journalists and
citizen media sort of sniping at one
another and I think it's actually become
a very complimentary environment it's
certainly one of the things that we end
up embracing about the environment um
Georgia we're going to move on uh from
you and and go visit with a friend of
ours in in Pakistan but thank you so
much for making the time uh for us and
thanks in particular for well no Chris
is going to cut me off here question I
think there we
go oh uh so Georgia I'm I'm showing a
picture of you here and uh there is a
furry animal on your shoulder it looks
like an overgrown version of the GV fret
uh and we're wondering there's a request
here to identify what the animal in fact
is okay that is that is a
lemur that that picture was taken when I
was in
Madagascar and um I went to Madagascar
actually to visit one of the um the
projects that Global voices supports
which is called fuk and um I could not
go to to to Madagascar without seeing
liur you know as as much as I understand
that it's not the only thing that's
interesting about Madagascar but so so I
I I think we're all sympathetic to the
notion that uh that that Madagascar is
more than lemurs and in fact we're going
to end up today uh uh with Loa rockat
Tamala so we're going to end up in
Madagascar but um one more question
actually I think we have time for one
more sorry great one more question yeah
if we have time uh yes um you you just
just mentioned that sort of antagonism
between traditional media and and
bloggers or or what have you is falling
off and I might try and tweak that not
not an antagonistic way but
uh I mean I'm I I've sort of struggled
for a long time to understand this term
because as a working journalist I I
didn't sort of lose my passport right I
continued to be a citizen and and this
idea that somehow what traditional
journalists do is is unimportant or I
struggle to understand for instance in
the particular case of Haiti a place
where I have experience it's
a complicated place to understand and to
explain and it certainly it's very
valuable if you know a few people can
Twitter and and be there because
correspondents are not based there
permanently
but I mean sort of two questions which
are interrelated is that I mean hati is
an enormously poor country and I mean we
should be and and you mentioned this
Georgia just now I mean we should be
honest that if people are twittering in
Haiti it's largely for the benefit of
people in the diaspora and and or people
who are interested in Haiti outside and
not in the country itself um and to sort
of try overly hard to sort of say oh we
should put all our resources into you
know more twittering I I I just wonder
if we're putting the cart before the
horse and and then I wondered I think
this is what we've been saying at all
actually I I thought we said the
opposite of this which was that um very
much that these two things are
complimentary and and that the hope is
to rebuild the media as a whole both
professional and and any sort of
informal so I I guess I'm just a little
confused by the
question um yeah I guess I'm confused as
well I'm I'm not I'm not questioning
clearly but we can I can sort of let let
you let you go on and we can talk
I I don't want to drone on so I drone on
enough already um I I
but Georgia do you want to react at all
to um I I missed part of the question
but um but yeah I I'm I'm with you Ethan
I I I think I I emphasized that I I
think the rebuilding the the media in
Haiti is is probably the the more
important issue than than creating a
core of you know you know people who
know how to do Twitter I mean let's be
honest the people the displaced people
in Haiti are you know weren't weren't
the ones tweeting as as as my um
interlocutor pointed out it was people
who had really not not been deeply
affected by the earthquake and who had
the the means to have a cell phone and
an internet connection that kind of
thing but yeah No I um I I don't I mean
we at Global voices we're always careful
to emphasize the complimentarity I think
of the of the two processes but I think
disasters are also peculiar in the the
the first reports that that you're going
to get from a a disaster zone are
probably going to be from people who are
not
journalists and um I think we need to
acknowledge that and and and you know
situate that material in in a you know
and give it it it's due
while understanding that that there is a
you know certainly research and and
factchecking and all that are are
critical to the the process of of
information sharing and and journalism
sure anyhow thank you I I just to add
maybe slightly more context to it um
George's work in Haiti was under um uh
internews uh which is a professional
media development organization uh that
received Grand funding to go over to
rebuild the professional media who then
invited Georgia to come over and work on
Citi media as a compliment to it so I I
guess if I'm responding to this I I mean
fundamentally we don't disagree it just
there's something and and maybe you know
this is a tangential thing and maybe I'm
wasting everyone's time but there's
something in the term citizen journalist
that just gets under my skin because I
mean it sort of implies that if you
become a journalist you're not a citizen
and this is so I mean there's something
about it that's always bothered me and I
mean really who cares what we call it
because it's a good thing and you know
there's many greater concerns in Haiti
than this but we've uh We've mostly been
trying to use the term uh uh citizen
Media or Civic media uh perhaps for
exactly that reason but uh perhaps we'll
make you happy by uh now going over to a
professional journalist who makes money
as a journalist doing so thank you so
much Georgia we appreciate you being
with us thank
you now from karach it's 3 a.m. joining
us in her
pajamas
youf I'm so sorry that we kept you
waiting we're so thrilled to have you uh
Huma uh is a journalist a professional
real journalist uh with dawn.com uh the
leading English language uh website and
uh and newspaper uh within Pakistan uh
and we'd love to talk to you about that
but we're also very interested in some
of the work that you've been doing
developing uh Community media uh within
Pakistan so I I I hope you'll uh you'll
take the time to tell us a little bit
about
that am I live can I be heard absolutely
are all right hello um thank you for
having me um citizen media in Pakistan
is that the
question uh citizen media in Pakistan
but even more than that you're doing all
this work on community media and trying
to build uh media cultures uh within
Pakistan we'd love to hear about
that well I particularly have been
working with um radio stations to some
extent we've been doing a lot of
interviews on the ground um which sort
of is is old media in the most classic
sense away from the conversation that
you've been having right now and I can
tell you a bit about that which is um I
think the reminder that you know should
have come up in several of the
conversations you've had this evening
that um in most of the countries we're
talking about the literacy rate remains
low in Pakistan the official rate is
about 46% which includes people who can
just write their name um internet
penetration in Pakistan which is a
nation of 100 and um 75 million people
is about 17 million people and it's
unclear that's a very sort of you know
contested statistic um and so in some
ways at the end of the day it does come
back to making better use um of old
media you know traditional media
mainstream media whatever you want to
call it which is one of the reasons I've
ended up after being at the center for
future Civic media as a researcher and
focusing on things like citizen
journalism and blogging and Twitter and
all of that I've come back to Pakistan
and become more excited about Community
radio stations um and what we're seeing
the the the areas I've been working in
mostly just helping radio stations with
some scripting um and with um sort of
better networking across themselves um
has been um um small community radio
stations along the Pakistan Afghanistan
border and what we found over there is
that the the tricks that we see online
things like collective intelligence
things like use of mobile phones to
share small nuggets of information um
this this these practices which now have
become come very linked with um sociable
media and citizen journalism and
Community organizing online um we've
taken a bunch of those and you know with
groups like internews um work to having
Community radio stations apply those to
improve um news reporting amongst these
smaller radio stations and just a little
little background on this issue so I'm
talking about the area where all the
horrible headlines about Pakistan come
out of so it's an area with extremely
low literacy with um violent Uprising
militancy um and this province
has um
150 illegal FM radio stations which were
being manned by extremist organizations
or being used as a way to um threaten
the local population and recruit
followers and things like that and um I
have I've been documenting this process
a little bit more than being fully
involved in it because there's a
language barrier where the language
where all these this radio programming
is happening is in PTO which is is a
regional language that I don't speak um
but what we've been doing is helping um
Community radio stations which means
stations that um have either been formed
by University students by groups of
journalists by um uh some have
Government funding they've sort of come
together to um do programming that can
push back against the sort of extremist
rhetoric that had dominated the airwaves
there so you've got about 15 legal radio
stations fighting off 150 or so illegal
which for the most part since I'd say
late 2009 they've shut down about 110 of
those after some military operations but
now the work that we have to do is to
work with the community radio stations
that do exist now these sort of
fledgling few um and very quickly what
what's sort of fun is that we're helping
our um radio journalists network with
each other using things like their cell
phones using things like Facebook using
Twitter and what we're having them do is
um sort of all the tools that you've
talked about the this is a this is a
population in which I don't think the
the sort of masses are ready yet they
don't even have television penetration
let alone internet penetration women
have limited ability so right now we're
empowering the journalists just to
communicate better amongst themselves to
get the word out um and what's most
exciting about this one sort of last
thought and then we can move on is um I
know this word was very popular at the
center of future Civic media last year I
hope it still is is this idea of
hyperlocal Journalism and what's really
unique about these radio stations is
that they're giving people um
programming that's literally local to
Villages of you know 12,000 people or
less in Pakistan is pretty small um and
and they and they even do things like a
very Craigslist sort of um you know they
set up markets using their radio station
um you know sort of offer to sell things
and they sort of broadcast that and the
journalist text message each other
things like that we've seen a lot um
there was a huge displacement of people
from this region and going to um sort of
a military operation against militancy
and organizing their transport and
alerting people about areas that you
know were closed down or that were
seeing militant activity or military
activity this sort of information was
all being shared by journalists who are
mostly just text messaging each other or
tweeting to a very small community and I
mean a community of 10 or 11 people um
but then sort of taking this online
activity and taking it straight to radio
skipping that midpoint of television so
it's been pretty interesting to get this
going so it if I'm understanding the
situation there uh and and one of the
things that's helpful for me in
understanding this is that um this
sounds very similar in some ways uh to
Citizen media and Mali uh which I've
been working on for many many years
where uh the only media that actually
effectively serves the community is the
radio station and to the extent that
we're trying to provide information to
anyone we're trying to provide it to the
people who are on air on the radio if
you can provide an internet connection
to a community radio station Suddenly
It's possible to get content from all
over the world and then get it out to
community radio is there interaction
between the communities where these
radio stations are located um how do
they interact with the radio station
locally is that uh a text message type
interaction or is it physically going to
the station or is that part of this or
is the interaction mostly from one radio
station to another radio
session um so just to clarify I'm
talking about one very particular strip
of Pakistan which is along the
Afghanistan borders we're talking about
one of the least developed part of the
country where there isn't much
television um there is however like in
the rest of Pakistan a lot of um cell
phone mobile penetration and um so you
do in terms of the community interacting
with their radio stations there's lots
of call-in talk shows those are the most
successful shows that the radio stations
do and uh the shows themselves are a
mixture of entertainment religious
programming music poetry um which sort
of hearkens back to what um the Iranian
speakers were talking about um and uh
and and the call-in shows um it's
usually phone calls um which are being
made either from fixed line telephones
but mostly and increasingly from um cell
phones um but not text messaging yet
because we're mostly talking about
communities that have a very low levels
of literacy um and and they've also come
up with wonderful systems where um they
they sort of give um the community radio
station sort of host a missed call they
sort of call and the host knows not to
pick up the phone and then the host will
call them back so in a way the the
stations are bearing the cost of
interacting with their listeners um and
uh one of the interesting things that's
sort of coming about is um because users
are being able to access radio stations
directly using their cell phones they
don't um a lot of women women who have
been in this part of the country sort of
confined to their homes who don't have
much sort of a voice in the public
sphere much of a presence in the public
sphere they being able to sort of ask
questions that's what they're doing most
of all given this opportunity but they
sort of call in and even do things like
request songs which for them is a
novelty and it's a very exciting and in
some ways empowering thing to be able to
do that Unfortunately they ask they
often request their host to sort of
relay their request or their question
under the name of a man so users don't
like like to go live um so they'll call
in speak to the host have a long chat
the hosts are usually so local so sort
of well known within the community that
for them it's like talking to a friend
um and then the host will sort of take
it back onto the air for everyone else
to listen
to so I I'm very interested in how your
work on the afpac border is it having
any influence on your work with dawn.com
are you finding ways of building
connections between what has to be sort
of elite media which is English language
media online uh and what's going on in
this community media uh in a very rural
and very disconnected area of the
country unfortunately there's a big
disconnect between these two things that
I work on um Dawn is a national English
language paper it's catering to the
Pakistani diaspora abroad and then to
the sort of Army in Pakistan and the
English speaking ruling Elite industrial
Elite um and the newspaper deals mostly
with with you know big headline issues
the sort of broad topics of national
interest like foreign policy defense
policy military activity things like
that and then obviously business and
economic stuff um and if anything I've
learned a sort of lesson that what's
missing from professional media in
Pakistan from mainstream media um is
this sort of hyperlocal activity that
the radio stations are able to achieve
um and um the other thing that one is
realized real izing though is that the
power of the mainstream media comes from
the fact that it um is National and it's
of really um well regulated at this
point a long history and what we're
finding with the radio stations are
they're extremely vulnerable um so you
know the stations can be jammed at any
point uh their funding may run out at
any point some of them are State
supported some of them have NGO grants
so it's all very unstable and pledgeling
at this point um and one wishes some of
that sort of Oran organization and
perhaps even commercial planning would
come into the radio stations that
professional journalism but I I do feel
like there's what I've learned
personally from this experience trying
to talk to the people at dawn about the
issues that matter to communities as big
as you know 3,000 people in a small
village with a tube well that's been
blocked up with silt um that sort of
reporting just doesn't happen in
National print at all and what we end up
having are papers that are sort of
dominated by broader policy issues so
we've got a question from the floor here
please sir yeah I'm wondering uh how
many people work with you at dawn and
how are you
supported um Dawn is a privately owned
um newspaper it's um the largest English
language daily in paristan so it has um
a reporting staff like the journalists
across the country of about um it
fluctuates between 160 to 180 or so the
actual sort of In-House editorial stuff
and all of that um it's it's a big
organization they about 300 people Dawn
is also affiliated with a television
channel and a radio channel so it's a
it's a big big um thing the website team
is much smaller there's only about 17 of
us um and um it's a commercial it's a
it's a privately owned it's a paper it
sells and it sort of pays for itself and
advertising revenues and all of that so
uh G given that we're setting here with
uh Center for future Civic media folks
and given that uh you've come out of
this program are now in in what I have
to assume is a pretty radically
different environment what's the biggest
thing that you would say based on your
experience in Pakistan that you would
want to give back to the folks here
involved with trying to build out Civic
media tools and
programs um I think that what I've seen
I used to say this a lot while I was
there as well but sort of coming back
it's really driven this point home is
that sort of local
um people adapt technology and make use
of it and it and play with it in ways
that are completely unexpected and it's
really important to start at the bottom
down and just um it seems like a very
simple thing to say but even just this
little culture of giving missed calls um
I had seen this before in another part
of Pakistan where a group of um women in
this tiny slum in Karachi which is the
city that I live in um they had come up
with this community policing system
where they had a whole they had a
prevalence of sort of domestic violence
issues and they several of them bought
each other other the cell phones and
they pull their money and save little
amounts of cash and bought a few phones
for women who are particularly having a
hard time with their husbands and they
came up with a system of missed calls um
where if a woman you know her husband
came home in a foul mood or he'd had
something to drink or whatever she would
just call her friends and she wouldn't
talk to them but they'd see the phone
ringing and they'd hang up and so they
wouldn't actually spend any money um so
it would take a very low sort of
investment from their part and then all
the women would sort of show up or
they'd send their husbands over to
invite the guy over for a couple tea or
whatever and they sort of protected each
other that way and it was such a simple
and yet smart way of doing something
which I don't think I could have thought
off if I was sitting in MIT and not you
know in there with them with their
problems thinking about it and I've seen
the same thing happen with some of the
journalists um who work for the radio
stations and at and some of the ways
that communities interact with
journalists things like um you know
they'll get on a truck um and they'll
they'll call um from each stop they'll
call um the radio station and let them
know about one particular issue um along
a particular route you know or they'll
um or they have another very complicated
system of missed calls where two missed
calls means call me back and three
missed calls means that there's a
military sign poost here and I'm going
to be in trouble soon so you won't hear
from me for a little while and it's just
it's simple stuff but it's all sort of
very locally it's very emergent and
local to the way that these people
communicate and I think that we should
have a lot of regard for that When
developing any sort of Technologies so
that's a a fantastic reminder and thank
you so much human and also we really
really appreciate you being with us so
late at night so thanks very
[Applause]
much so uh our our next three speakers
are are going to bring us over uh into
talking about Civic media in an African
context uh and we were first going to
try to uh bring up Ruth Ruthie Akerman
uh who's has been involved with a
project called uh ceasefire Liberia how
are we doing on that Chris uh it looks
good live hey Ruthie hi thank you for
having me tonight uh it's such a
pleasure to have you here and uh
ceasefire L be is a is a project that
I've admired for a long time but I'm
wondering if you could start by uh
telling the room here uh what is
ceasefire Liberia what's it been trying
to do and uh what's it what does it
meant as far as getting Liberian voices
out into the internet as a
whole okay thought I'd start a little
bit by giving you a little history about
why I went to Liberia in the first place
and the reasons for starting it because
I thought that would give you a good
background um I had already been writing
about Africa when I went to Liberia and
especially specifically writing about
women in politics so when President
surle was elected in 2005 there was a
lot of momentum and energy and I was
super excited about the fact that there
is finally a woman president in Africa
and
that she believes in democracy and there
is going to be this Beacon of Hope in
the region and in the country so um when
a delegation of women from Harvard asked
me to join them on a trip to Liberia to
train women civil society leaders in
politics I thought this is great this is
the opportunity to actually see this
kind of work in action I went on this
trip in December of 2006 which was
almost one year after president Sur Leaf
was inaugurated and my job as a
journalist was to write stories about
president sirleaf's first year in office
so I was mostly looking at the
challenges that surle was facing um in
her first year but what struck me when I
arrived in Liberia was that was really
the young people that I met there and
the challenges that they were facing
rebuilding their lives at the same time
that sirleaf was facing these challenges
rebuilding the country after 14 years of
Civil War so I met former Child soldiers
I met War traumatized youth I met
amputees I met a lot of different uh
people that had been through the war and
I was just writing their stories
documenting these stories so on when I
got home from this trip I began
researching even more intensively about
Liberia and realized that one of the
largest communities in uh the United
States one of the largest communities of
liberians in the United States was right
in my own backyard in Staten Island New
York so immediately I went out to Staten
Island and I began uh writing about the
young people that I met in Staten Island
as well I was going out and hanging out
in the places that the young people
spent time in the parking lots behind
the buildings in various apartments in
having dinner eating with them and
really just writing their stories and
hearing about their lives here in the
United States so I Al at that point I
decided to apply for a grant from the
Pitzer Center on crisis reporting to do
a project to write about uh how young
liberians are rebuilding their lives
both in Liberia but also in Staten
Island uh I thought that there were many
similarities in the um types of stories
I was seeing both uh liberians in Staten
Island and in Liberian were struggling
to integrate or reintegrate into their
communities and I was F fascinated by
the struggle and by the um by the
similarities and so I wanted to write
about that and at the same time this
light bulb went off in my head about
here I am as an outsider writing about
these two communities in saten island
and in Liberia that are not my own
communities they're not my own stories
to tell but yet I'm writing these
stories and so I thought what if I
created a space where these like young
liberians could write about their own
lives their own own communities at the
same time that I'm writing about them
and their communities so that's how
ceasefire Liberia the idea for ceasefire
Liberia was born um at the same time can
you still see me we still see you we
just wanted to uh lower the link and and
make sure that we could see you okay no
problem I just wanted to make sure um at
the same time um so that's how cire
Liber is born but another aspect that I
wanted to make sure I pointed out was
that I wanted to connect the liberians
in Liberia with those in the diaspora so
there were so many misconceptions I was
hearing from liberians on both sides of
the oceans myths that I was hearing in
Liberia the um a lot of the young people
were saying that they thought the
liberians living in the US were their
lives were easy that money was found on
the streets that it was the land of milk
and honey and um liberians in the US
were saying had all these myths about
liberians back in Liberia saying that um
they were lazy they weren't working they
just wanted to ask for money from their
family in the US so I thought that by
creating this dialogue that um that
would help to dispel some of these myths
because I thought that uh at least one
of the reasons for the war in Liberia
was that this lack of communication this
lack of dialogue so if we kept the
dialogue open that that would um help in
terms of rebuilding the country and
repairing the relationships so so we've
just we've just heard from our our
friend uh Huma yusf about the importance
of community media on the Afghanistan
Pakistan border and what's been going on
there with Community radio stations and
trying to build media that's capable of
serving a local community it sounds like
what you're really talking about is
building media that can serve a Liberian
Community that's sort of weirdly split
between West Africa uh and also a burrow
of of New York City is the same type of
media something like a website like
ceasefire Liberia able to reach both
audiences how are you reaching this
audience uh in Monrovia and in the rest
of the country where infrastructure is
even more
scarce it's it's very difficult and it's
one of the things that I wanted to talk
about because when I started this
project I figured that there would be
this digital divide and my hypothesis um
and I think I wrote this in my
application to Global voices when I
applied for the grant was that um the
liberians in Sten Island who have more
access to the internet because they're
here in the US would be blogging a lot
more than liberians in Liberia where the
internet is expensive and it's very slow
and that's only in Monrovia in the rural
areas or anywhere outside of Monrovia
the internet's almost non-existent so my
idea was that the bloggers in Sten
Island and the rest of the dias
would be blogging much more than those
in Liberia but in reality what has
happened over the last year since we've
been up and running is that liberians in
Liberia have been blogging much more
than those in the US and I've thought
about it a lot I haven't um I've asked
but I haven't done extensive research
but I think that the reason why is that
there's this sense of urgency in Liberia
that they really want to get their
stories out there and that if they don't
tell their stories they won't be told
and so um there is this digital divide
but the at least in mon Monrovia um
those stories are being told on the
ceasefire Liberia blog but one thing I
wanted to point out in one of the
challenges I've had is with the gender
digital divide I thought that because I
was coming to this project with an
inherent interest in writing about women
and my stories that I tend to write um
in my own journalism are about women I
thought that by default I guess uh women
bloggers would be drawn to this site and
would want to um write to for Seas fire
Liberia and I have found that that is
not what has happened there are many
reasons I don't know if you've spoken
about this already I had trouble getting
on the live stream but um there are many
reasons why there for this gender
digital divide and general uh poverty is
one of them in Liberia there's low
literacy rates in uh Liberia the
education during the war was almost
non-existent so that was um so it was
difficult to um to go to school during
the war and on top of that women aren't
used to having a voice uh not used to
this idea that you can speak out in your
communities and write about your lives
um I thought that because we're not only
writing on the blog but also using video
and photography that there'd sort of be
something for everyone and so I would be
able to get women to participate as well
um but one other thing I wanted to point
out was that another reason that I
thought that Liberian women would
participate is because there's so much
talk with presidenta in office of um
like of empowerment of women there's
been initiatives to uh have women and
Child Protection units in the police
stations there's been uh specialized
rape court that President Sur has
initiated there's been a lot of talk
about uh women and politics but um when
it comes to actually blogging that
hasn't translated into uh citizen media
so it sounds like um as with all great
citizen media projects you end up with a
number of questions that you don't have
good answers to why is it that it's
easier to get people to blog from
Monrovia than it is from Staten Island
uh why is it so difficult to get women
to speak um you sent some really
striking images uh and I'm just going to
show them right now I'm just wondering
if you can talk a little bit about why
images uh have been such an important
part of of this process uh why is it
that that images have been uh such a big
part of sort of Citizen media in a
Liberian
context um well I wanted I'll give you a
little background on some of the images
I can't really see what you're showing
but um the images that I sent were from
recent violence in voima which was one
of the hardest hit areas in Liberia
during the war and very recently
violence broke out in voima when a young
Liberian Girl was found murdered um it
was a Christian girl and that's
important because her parents and the
community felt that because her body was
found supposedly near a mosque that um
she must have been murdered by the
Muslims which started a um a riots riots
broke out and four people ended up dead
and many houses were burnt and churches
were burnt and mosques were burnt so
this was only in the last month that
this happened um so our blog manager who
his name is Nat noan BJ and he's been
wonderful he's been my counterpart in
Monrovia in terms of recruiting other
bloggers but also and he writes a lot
for us he uh risked his own life going
to voima and also left his family uh in
Monrovia to go to voima to take those
photographs that you're looking at and
also to write a series of stories for us
about what was happening in bu jimo why
this violence broke out um and what is
being done about it so this um again I
can't see the the photographs but there
were a few I I sent he had done a story
about a um two men who had bullets still
inside their bodies um and actually
after he wrote that story someone who
read it had contacted some doctors about
the possibility of doing some surgery on
one of the men uh so there's been a lot
of encouraging things that have come out
of this work um another thing I want to
mention about this specifically about
this work in boima was that no one else
is covering is covering this stuff no
the big media Outlets BBC whoever is
usually covering these stories have not
been covering these stories in Liberia
so in terms of an international audience
and getting these stories out really
there's only cire liberan maybe one or
two other blogs that people um that
people read so that is why it's so
important that a project like this
exists so um I I think just in in terms
of thinking about sort of the Arc of our
event here uh we're having this sort of
Whirlwind tour of the globe and we're
sort of moving from High Media attention
to lower media attention we've we've
gone from Iran and talking about the
Iranian Revolution and Haiti with a lot
of attention to the earthquake we're
going to end up in Madagascar which may
be the only country that I can think of
going through political violence that
gets less attention uh than Liberia
I'm wondering if just as as a Parting
Shot um you want to essentially tell us
what's the biggest Liberian story that
Americans are missing and and probably
should be paying attention
to oh there's a few of them I think but
one of them is that uh president sterle
is going to run for office again she
announced that recently and she had said
when she was first elected to office
that she would only serve one term uh so
many people are outraged that she's
running again they think that she's
supposed to be the symbol of democracy
and here she is trying to hold on to
power and I think that that has been
something that has been there's been
anger over many issues in Liberia in the
five years that she's been in office um
and I think that this is this anger
there's some anger under the surface
that's beginning to boil up uh there's
anger that um the rural communities are
extremely angry that they're many of
their needs they don't think have been
met over the last um five years uh there
are many uh women that are angry that
they think that their needs haven't been
met and I think that a lot of it is
starting to boil up now and with sirleaf
running for office again I think we're
going to see some of that um start to to
brew even more as we get closer and
closer to election day so I'm uh gearing
up with uh some other partners to really
uh train more more uh citizen
journalists and really try to get
ceasefire Liberia prepared for the
election and for some coverage to follow
I I Ruthie thank you so much for being
with us and I also I just want to
acknowledge um to this group Ruthie is
one of uh the the people we're going to
feature today who who've been involved
with global voices in one fashion or
another and we've tried a number of uh
media projects in postconflict countries
uh and for the most part they don't work
uh and actually what's been so
astounding is being able uh to have um
this much information and so much
incredible reporting coming out of
Liberia uh so thank you uh not just for
being with us tonight but thank you for
the amazing work that you're doing on uh
making sure that we understand the
situation in Liberia a little bit
better thank you so much thanks
everyone so uh as we as we uh talk about
Civic media in difficult places uh and
conversations that can be difficult to
have
uh I want to introduce uh our next
guests uh Brenda Burell and and Bev
Clark um who are uh calling in in
perhaps the toughest circumstances of
everyone uh this evening uh they're
going to be calling in from uh Harari
Zimbabwe uh where not only is it the
middle of the night but the it's the
middle of the night uh which lately has
been routinely interrupted by power Cuts
uh and uh they've been going through
some real struggles as far as uh
maintaining connectivity uh to some of
their uh incredibly important uh citizen
media projects uh uh Bev and Brenda are
uh really just inspiring leaders uh who
are pillars of Civil Society within
Zimbabwe uh and who've been involved
with just utterly fascinating efforts to
build uh Community media in a country
where building Community media uh is an
incredibly difficult thing to do uh so
guys I I would uh love to ask you uh
first of all to say a word or two about
kubatana uh but then ideally uh tell us
a word or two about uh the freedom phone
project that you've been working
on hey hi
Ethan hi can you hear me it's bab
speaking hey Bev it's great to hear you
did you hear our question at
all I did hear your question and I just
want to say thank you very much for that
wonderful um introduction so I think
I'll start off Ethan telling you a
little bit about
kubatana and then Brenda can jump in and
um Describe freedom phone for you um
about 10 years ago we started kubatana
with the specific intention of trying to
make the NGO sector in Zimbabwe and the
publishing that it produces um more
accessible to zimbabweans the region and
also
globally and we started off very small
we kited around a question questionaire
to all those Zimbabwean NOS that we knew
of and we showed them our kind of
Illustrated idea of what our website
would finally look like we got amazing
support from the sector in Zimbabwe and
today we run a website which um archives
has a library of over 16,000 documents
largely about um activities in the
nonprofit sector
we have a directory of over 240
NOS we produce a weekly email newsletter
to a subscriber list of about
9,400 people our SMS subscriber list um
has grown just recently to over 10,000
people we've started a community blog
where I think we have now over about 16
contributors and what we like
specifically about our community blog is
that zimbabweans contribute their
perspectives of on the ground life here
and actually I urge you to read a post
that I put up today about a woman's
field trip into a very rural space in
Zimbabwe in in the quest to actually
dispense medication for
measles so um our use of icts has been
very integrated and basically how we've
approached it is to look at the fact
that many different people have
different accesses to different tools
and ways of communication and we've
tried to spread our expertise and skills
over a variety of mediums in order to
attract and build participation from a
wide variety of
zimbabweans we also have gone into print
um especially over election time when we
feel that the information is being
severely controlled by the government in
terms of voter education
materials and um just
recently we've also engaged Freedom
phone um our audio information
dissemination project to carry audio
materials to um
again to a wide variety of zimbabweans
so at this point in time I think I I do
think that kater is seen as one of
Africa's ICT success stories we're we're
really proud of what we've developed and
um I think I recall you saying in the
introduction we have indeed developed
what we feel is a community we have a
very loyal following of zimbabweans who
look to for nonpartisan information and
information um actually that inspires
them our take on disseminating
information is that you need to create
hope you need to continue to be
optimistic but at the same time you also
need to be defiant and in your power
about your rights and we've combined
those sorts of elements and we feel that
we are creating a more empowered zimb in
general public at least those people who
consume our
information I'm not too sure if you have
any specific questions about what I've
said but otherwise I'll hand you over to
Brenda well Bev I'd love to to just ask
one thing before we sort of move over
and and talk about Freedom phone um it's
I just want everyone here to sort of
understand the context of this a little
bit better uh one of the things that I
love about talking to the two of you is
that you have this incredibly successful
NGO you work with all of these other NOS
you're bringing them online you're
telling hopeful stories very personal
stories about what's going on uh one
thing that I noticed that the two of you
never talk about unless you're prompted
is just how difficult the environment is
to do community media in Zimbabwe and I
was wondering if you would just explain
to the audience here that doesn't know
Zimbo very well um how difficult it is
to do community radio how difficult and
how dangerous it is to produce print
newsletters in the Zimbabwe and media
environment if uh if I got you right
Ethan uh you broke up a lot there but
I'm thinking that you are asking us
about describing our media
environment um if that is the case
working in a bit of a um an audio vacuum
here um a lot of being in Zimbabwe and
being an activist in Zimbabwe means
basically putting your head above the
parit and not being afraid to
disseminate information when there are
many factors working against you um in
fact I was thinking um about this chat
on on the way here tonight and one of
the things I did today was I went to a
demonstration in downtown Town Harari
that was organized by woman of Zimbabwe
arise um I'm sure you've heard of of
them they are very vibrant uh female Le
activist group here and they were
protesting about the poor service
actually of the national power supply um
company and as you mentioned in your
introduction our power supplies are
incredibly erratic these days but when I
was downtown and watching them today
there were over 500 wom there they were
waving yellow cards um basically using
the soccer metaphor of giving the
national Supply Authority a warning
saying listen we're watching you and
zimbabweans need more stable power
supply so so watch out and when I was
there it it struck me that no matter how
many icts or groovy sexy New Media tools
you have if you don't have the passion
if you don't have the drive to
communicate in difficult situations and
environments like Zimbabwe then
basically you just won't make it so I
think what what we have here is a medor
environment that is very very shut down
as you know we don't particularly have
Free Press we don't have a daily um
Independent Newspaper we don't have free
radio stations or TV
stations and uh what is particularly
disturbing is the amount of fear that is
pervasive in
Zimbabwe um people have actually laughed
we are a nation that does like a good
joke but people say that we walk around
with a crick in our neck because we're
always looking over our shoulder
wondering who's watching us us or who's
listening to us so I think that um being
engaged in community and Civic media in
in a country like Zimbabwe forces us to
innovate and I think that's what Kitana
has done very
successfully um forcing us to innovate
and as well as that being
consistently courageous um I believe
that one of our successes and one of the
successes of publishing and of moving
information is to be consistent people
have to realize that you are not to fly
by night that you that you're there weak
in and weak out and that you build a
trust between yourself and your audience
and whoever you're networking with um
last year kubatana actually got an award
for media responsibility from the n
B
associate I think Charlie 10 are
interfering with your connection at the
moment
wait Chris do you want to try to reset
or why don't we why don't we hang up and
let's see if we can bring uh Brenda back
in to talk about if you just send a t
let's see if we can get Brenda back talk
just really briefly about Freedom phone
uh I I just want to add a little context
to this um it's almost impossible to do
independent media in Zimbabwe um
zimbabweans are enormously influential
in Independent Media in southern Africa
uh and the Mel and guardian which is
probably the best paper on the continent
uh is a Zimbabwe and run newsp paper
coming out of South Africa uh but if you
want to do a community radio station in
Zimbabwe for the last several years
you've really had to be prepared to go
to prison to do so uh and very very
smart organizations um have put together
fascinating hacks to try to figure out
how you do community radio because as we
were talking before with Huma you really
want radio that's reaching the people uh
up until recently state-of-the-art for
how you do Community radio in Zimbabwe
without getting arrested is you produce
Community radio and you produce it on
cassette tapes and you hand it out to
van drivers who drive long-distance bus
routes and you try to build a mix
between music and political programming
so that they won't be terrified of
playing the political stuff because it's
broken up by music one of the things
that kubatana has been incredibly
incredibly experimental in doing and has
done just gorgeous work on is figuring
out how how we might end up using mobile
phones to do community radio and we're
hoping to to bring Brenda back into the
conversation to sort of talk about this
any luck on that um no they turned down
twice but I just got a text through so
we should be okay uh just so everyone
knows this is the second to last speaker
and I think the last speaker will only
be about another 15 minutes or so so um
you know stick through the end if you
can uh but yeah we don't seem to be
connecting to be I if you could just let
them know I'm going to talk very briefly
about Freedom phone and then we're going
to move on to Loa who's our last speaker
so assume for the moment that in
Zimbabwe it's basically impossible to
run an independent radio station on the
other hand you have massive mobile phone
penetration lots and lots of people have
mobile phones what uh Bev and Brenda
ended up working on is a way to do radio
type programming over the mobile phone
and this involves building an
inexpensive uh interactive voice
response system you send a text message
to the system and it calls you back and
says hey what sort of content would you
like press one if you want recent
headlines press two if you want uh a
discussion on political Affairs press
three if you're looking for
inspirational music um what's most
incredible about the system is not only
is it an open source system that's being
rolled out for use in multiple locations
but the political environment in
Zimbabwe is finally Gra gradually
starting to change and something that's
enormously interesting is that uh one of
the ministers the minister for
constitutional Affairs has recently
agreed to come on freedom phone and
field questions from the general
population about the Zimbabwean
Constitution um so here's a a very
creative use of New Media as a way to
create a public space that just doesn't
exist
otherwise Chris where are we on as far
as well so we uh
Brenda says she's sure you'll do a good
job describing Freedom phone uh and then
um but we tried calling back three times
no luck um and then uh Lova is not
answering um who is our last speaker uh
uh was online
last uh 6:38 or so um uh so uh Loa is
not answering but um uh I can try one
more time uh so so let's let's try once
more and see if we get Loa on uh in the
meantime in general any questions that
have sort of come up for people here uh
about what we're getting in this sort of
scattershot polistic view of of Citizen
media around the planet uh anything that
anyone wants to observe bring up sort of
talk
about this is me vamping and you can
help me by standing up and yes please
wonderful um everything I'm hearing
makes me um think that journalists here
could be doing more reporting
from here with people in places like
Zimbabwe and Haiti and I want to ask you
technically what are the how much
bandwidth do we have in some of these
developing countries because if it's
getting to the point where we could
Skype with people in in Haiti and um
Zimbabwe can we start interviewing you
know from our desks using Skype I mean
how how far are we away from doing that
you know and second question part two um
I've heard of like Frontline SMS and
these SMS messaging systems and I
wondered if there's any grant money or
any projects out there that are looking
at something like a super cell phone
maybe a something between a netbook in a
cell phone and fund handing out these
netbooks so that people can go a step
further than just receiving messages is
there anything out there like that
thanks those are really great questions
um actually looks like we have Loa so um
maybe we couldn't put those in the quebe
so we're going to circle circle back to
those um I just want to point out that
there are drinks for everyone upstairs
immediately after this we have to quit
right at 7even so that might be a
question that we uh do over cocktails um
sorry to a let me apologize and and here
should be
Loa I hope he
answers we've been doing so well with
Skype up until this point you have to
say I mean given how many people in how
many countries think that's Zimbabwe we
we we we we're uh drawing in well this
is I mean hilariously now our problem is
actually getting to Princeton so um I
think we have Princeton Loa you
there someone's Breathing
heavily so um while Chris works on this
let me let me try yes I'm here hey Loa
wonderful we're so glad to have you here
um Loa we've been having this uh sort of
crazy Globe hopping
conversation about the power of Civic
media uh and particularly we've been
talking about this idea that Civic media
uh can help us get information from
places that we don't normally hear from
uh and it's been I think a real surprise
to some people here to have voices
coming out of Liberia voices coming out
of Zimbabwe um how has Civic Media made
it possible for people in Madagascar to
tell their stories tell us a little bit
about uh about fuku club and what that's
meant as far as uh malagi people telling
their stories to the
world okay so uh fuku Madagascar has now
trained uh 65 bloggers all over
Madagascar with various
interest and uh uh the purpose of fuku
was to highlight and promote on the web
grassroot Association working uh in
environmental social changes and uh we
figur that if give a platform to those
Association we could um uh those
Association could greatly benefit from
The increased exposure via feedback so
collaboration right so uh we did that
for two years but then as you all may
know there was the political turmoil in
Madagascar and uh it turned quite
violent and uh result resulted in the
ating of uh the president uh with the
support of the Army on uh March 17 of
last year
so uh the so basically the people that
we train now uh didn't have uh kind of
turn um by default to a document the
crisis and um and it was uh clearly
quite important because uh freedom of
press which was already under attack
before the coup was uh certainly more
shut down now uh because the new
government wanted to provide an image of
legitimacy and being the People's Choice
and that was clearly not the case so uh
what the bloggers that we train did was
uh basically to
uh uh to uh to provide real life
information of what was happening uh in
Madagascar so let's just talk a little
bit about who these bloggers are because
I I I I think people here are sort of
imagining uh you know trained
professional journalists who who are the
sorts of people who were involved with
fuku club right so uh the very first uh
uh fuku Club bloggers were actually uh
high school students from uh from uh a
public school in in Madagascar they just
came to us and they were interested in
uh learning a little bit more about
information Technologies so they were
the first one that we train now uh among
uh all the loggers that we have we have
uh uh environmental activists that are
uh trying to uh to protect the forest uh
on the East Coast we also have um
healthc care givers in the south in the
south of Madagascar and um yeah so none
of those guys were uh professional
bloggers per se they were really just
interested in uh learning more and uh
that's when
um um and uh basically but uh this
training that they had helped them uh
document everything that was going on
when uh when the the the social uh
fabric of Madagascar turned a little
different so so just to to sort of wind
back in time you have a club that really
starts as um high school students who
initially wanted to learn a little bit
more English uh then started to want to
learn a little bit about technology
ended up learning about blogging
um and have now turned into um really
some of the most independent voices
coming out of the malasi crisis for the
simple reason that a lot of radio and
television voices have been silenced as
someone managing this project um what
does it mean that you're sending out
high school students uh to literally go
out and and report from the barricades I
mean how do we do this and I say we
because of course we're supporting this
project over at Global voices is is
there is there concern uh about these
young people uh sort of going out and
and doing what could be some very
dangerous journalistic
work there is definitely a major concern
especially around uh March and April of
last year because that's when we we
could see that there were people being
killed in the street uh what we our
first initial reaction uh when we saw
that they were documenting the crisis
was uh why exactly are you out in the
street right now you should be at home
and just uh close the door and and be
safe but uh really that was what we as
the core team told them we we told them
at first that this was really not what
the objective was of of the training but
uh they just felt that uh it was their
duty to to um to tell more about what
was happening because them themselves at
home didn't see anything on television
or on radio about what was really
happening so it was more it was coming
from from the bloggers themselves they
they felt like uh this is happening and
we need to tell the people outside that
uh that this is this is how it is and um
and and maybe people are are missing the
picture here so so just before you
joined us lva we had a a great question
from the audience and the question was
basically if it's possible for us to
have a conversation with a blogger in
Madagascar over Skype why is it that
we're not getting more information out
of places like Madagascar is it a
technology constraint that we're not
able to make the call to antano or what
are the other constraints is the problem
that uh we tend to think that Madagascar
is a place where scheming piglins go to
overthrow the government rather than
thinking of it is an actual uh real
place on the
map uh I think it's uh OD a little bit
of all of that at once uh I think one of
the major issue is still uh language
clearly uh when we trained our uh our
bloggers to um uh to use a citizen media
platform we also encourage them to to uh
to blog a little bit in English because
uh that would increase the uh the
ability for for other people to to
understand what they're talking about uh
I think the technology is still a major
constraint uh because uh even though
we're supposed to have the faster
Broadband right now it's really not
quite there for the majority of the
population uh and finally I think that
it's a little bit about uh people not
understanding that there's a lot of uh
good stories that they could tell and
that they could tell the story in a in a
more repealing way so that uh people get
more interested about what's going on
there so I think it's it's a bit of uh
of all of that now clearly there might
be a lack of interest for madagasca when
it when it's not about uh the
environment or uh you know the the lers
but uh I think it's it's also about us
not telling a competing story as well
well embarrassingly enough we actually
had a question before Georgia popo
showed up with a lemur on her shoulder
uh so we've actually already filled it a
lemur question so we we've already given
into to every malagi stereotype uh or at
least the American malagi stereotypes um
look I I just want to recognize um one
of the reasons I wanted to close uh with
you talking a little bit about fuku is
that we've been
astounded by people's willingness um to
do incredibly hard work to put their
country on the map digitally um not only
have we seen high school students going
out and doing really intensive polit IC
reporting uh but right now there's a a
global voices project in malagi uh Loa
talk to me just really quickly in
closing about why it's important uh to
bring the malasi language and citizen
media in malagi uh onto the
internet right um I think what motivated
the the the global voices in malagi
project was uh we feel at times because
we're an island that we're a little bit
isolated from the conversation that's
happening in the rest of the world and
uh the Mal uh we take great pride in uh
in the malagi language it's uh it's it's
it's spoken all over the country it's
one of the uh one of the reason why we
feel that uh the malasi identity can be
uh highlighted because it's a it's an
old language it's um it's what unit us
basically and uh so we figured that if
we were going to tell us stories uh in
English and in other languages it would
be it would just make sense for us to
also bring stories from other part of
the word in malagi and I think this uh
this translation effort really uh helped
us gather more ideas from uh how people
were were doing things outside and also
help tell our stories so this two-way
street really was a win-win situation
for uh for the malagi blogosphere
uh can can we get a goodbye from you in
malagi oh
[Music]
sure so one of the things that I've been
learning about malagi is that it has
more syllables than I could ever
possibly imagine uh but filled with
respecta so
uh the short version there Loa thank you
so much uh for for uh being our closing
speaker and and sharing a little bit
with us and I'm going to urge everybody
here to take a close look at fuku
because I think it's actually one of the
very most inspiring projects uh it's the
project that I show off every time I
talk about the power of Citizen media uh
so thanks for spending a little bit of
time uh with us tonight uh and everyone
here thanks for hanging in for uh what
has not always been the most technically
Flawless event uh but I I thought ended
up being sort of an interesting
conversation and I hope maybe we can
continue it uh outside over some drinks